you
hi I'm Simon Hays and I'm a production
sound mixer a production sound mixer in
film or television is the man or woman
that records the spoken dialogue and the
sound effects that actually happened
during the shoot of the film so it's my
responsibility to make sure that the
actors voices are recorded as cleanly as
possible with as little background noise
as possible and any sound effects that
are incidental while we're shooting are
also recorded so that afterwards the
sound design team can add my clean
dialogue recordings and my sound effects
recordings to more produce sound effects
recordings and music to create the final
soundtrack I work with a team and my
team are really important to me
filmmaking is always collaborative in
every department and I rely on my team
enormous ly getting production good
production sound isn't just down to the
production sound mixer you've got to
have a good boom operator a good second
boom operator the second boom operator
is the sound maintenance engineer so
generally the sound team on a normal
traditional movie will be four people it
will be the production sound mixer the
boom operator the sound maintenance
engineer who also swings the second boom
and the sound trainee who's obviously
training with us getting carpet down
underneath actors feet whenever we can
so that we don't have footsteps over the
dialogue and and generally learning the
ropes with us the boom operator has an
amazingly talented job to do he needs to
learn the dialogue as if he's an actor
because the boom needs to swing between
the dialogue if you've got different
different actors on set talking to each
other the boom needs to be moving
between them it can't just stay in the
middle because of course we're using a
directional mic to try and cancel out
the background noise that we don't want
to pick up so if the boom isn't pointing
exactly that the actors mouth the actor
is going to sound wide I'm going to have
to bring the gain up and the background
noise is going to come up so what the
boom operator has to do is cue the
microphone in between the dialogue but
not only that he needs to make sure that
the mic doesn't dip into frame because
of course if the mic dips into frame
then we have to do a retake if that was
a fantastic performance for the actor
then we've let the actor down and and
the director and everyone on the movie
set so the boom operator needs to know
his lens sizes he needs to know exactly
how close he can get to the to the edge
of frame because the closer he is to the
edge of frame the less gain or volume I
have to use and if I use less gain
volume then we get less background noise
if we get less background noise and
cleaner dialogue it means that a the the
performance sounds better in the cinema
but also it means that the sound design
team in the dub afterwards have an
opportunity to bring up the sound
effects and bring up the music more
because they've got better cleaner
dialogue to work with so everyone
benefits from having clean dialogue so
the boom operator if I can just give an
example if you've got an actor sitting
here in an actor sitting here the boom
operator will have the boom there and on
the lines he'll be cueing from one act
of speaking swinging across in between
the lines to the other act of speaking
if there's a third actor to that third
actor and then back to that actor on the
dialogue the sound maintenance engineer
again is the second boom operator when
we need to run two booms we get two
booms out we put them on two separate
tracks to give the sound editorial team
a chance to to marry those tracks
together it gives you twice as much
chance of getting great sound if you use
two booms the sound maintenance engineer
will also be responsible for making sure
day-to-day issues like the radio mic
channels when we use radio mics like the
one that I'm using here will make sure
that the radio mic channels are free for
the location we're working in making
sure that the actors are rigged with
radio mics when we need them before they
come onto set and generally being my
right-hand man so my team is really
important to me it's so collaborative
ladies ER habla was an incredibly
challenging process because it was
unique in many ways
Tom's vision of Lamy Zurab ler is a
completely Sun through musical so not
only is it a live sound recording but
also there's no dialogue when you think
about the traditional musical format for
filmmaking you have a song and dance
routine which the actors mind too then
you have a group of dialogue scenes that
tell a story and then you go back into
another song and dance routine so the
song and dance routines are broken up
with live dialogue scenes where you have
spoken dialogue storytelling Lamy zaraba
of course is sung from start to finish
so tom rightly made a decision that he
couldn't have the actors mining for two
and a half hours i just don't think
there would have been a connection with
the audience so what was incredible
about his vision was that he wanted to
give the actors the opportunity to sing
live but that's not the whole story what
was really exciting was he didn't want
them locked to tempo of course even if
you have actors sing live if you're
playing them back into a hidden earpiece
a pre-recorded piece of music it doesn't
matter that they're singing live they
still have to stick to tempo if they
want to pause for a moment and have a
have a think about an emotive issue in
their performance if they want to have a
moment to cry because of scenes sad or
even if they want to take a moment to
walk across a room before they sing
their next line if they're tied to a
pre-recorded tempo from a pre-recorded
piece of music they can't do that where
Tom's vision was extremely exciting and
unique was that not only did he want
them singing live but he wanted them to
be able to set the tempo so there was no
pre-recorded music at all what we did
was we had a pianist and the pianist
played into the ear pieces but the
pianist was asked by Tom to never ever
lead the actors the pianist was in a
soundproof box off the edge of the set
and she basically had him had a monitor
for each camera we were shooting three
cameras and she would watch the
performance and she would take her
you from the actors so that basically
what would happen was that acting took
precedent over the tempo of the music it
meant that on what have I done or
dreamed a dream
it meant that human Annie had enormous
scope to be emotive wherever they wanted
to whenever they thought their character
should take a pause or have a thought
they could do whatever they wanted to
what was so challenging and exciting
about that was the fact that afterwards
the orchestra was shown the final cut of
the movie and they played to that cut
so an orchestra on a normal film would
play to sheet music on lame is they
played to the actors performances on a
screen in front of them and I'm sure
that that has a huge huge effect on just
how emotive and the connection that the
audiences felt with those performances
that in turn gave the cast a huge
confidence that when they put in those
hugely emotional performances that they
would be recorded well enough to be used
in the final film
I'm proud of the whole of Lainey's there
was one scene in the movie that we had
to do to lip-sync and that was the scene
at the very beginning when the convicts
were pulling in the boat that scene was
unachievable to record life so what we
did we wild tracked the actors before
they shot the scene on the same
microphones that we shot the rest of the
movie on and we had to playback this
there they're singing through huge
speakers because we had wind machines
with VW beetle engines blowing their
hair everywhere we had wave machines
smashing them with waves as they were
putting that ship in but from that
moment when the ship arrives when
Russell Crowe first meets Hugh Jackman
from that moment for the rest of the
movie every solo vocal performance is
the performance that we recorded on the
set there was no rerecords those are the
real performances and I'm incredibly
proud of that but if there was one scene
that I'd like to talk about that really
does depict the challenges in
collaboration between the film crew the
actors and the sound and music team it
was on my own which Samantha barks sings
in the scene she's she's walking down
rue de plume a in Paris it's raining and
she basically does a hugely emotional
performance it's not allowed
performances it starts off very very
low-key under her breath
I walk with him till morning let's talk
about the first challenge which was the
rain we shot that on a soundstage which
which meant that we had to use false
rain it was a it was rain rig set up by
the special effects team the
collaboration with the special effects
team started with the fact that we told
them that we had to have a very very
fine spray of rain because of course the
bigger the rain droplets the more likely
it is that you're going to get a big
drop of rain hitting a microphone and
basically water logging it and ruining
the take the second problem with big
droplets of rain is the bigger the drop
of rain the more noise it's going to
make when it hits the cobblestones that
she's walk walking on and but and let's
let's bear in mind we can see the whole
street you're gonna hear the droplets of
rain hitting the rooftop of all of the
buildings around her every single hard
surface ok can potentially sound like a
drum when you have big drops of rain
hitting it so the first thing that we
did was we adjusted the spray of the
rain into an extremely fine spray we did
this with collaboration not just from
the special effects department but from
Tom Hooper and Danny Cohen his fantastic
DP Danny was looking through the cameras
we were adjusting the rain before we
even started rehearsing with Sam and
what we did was we brought the spray
down so that it was finer and finer and
finer until Danny said ok guys you've
gone too far now we can't actually see
that rain through camera and at that
point we brought the rain up just very
slightly so that Danny was happy that
the camera could read it so we knew then
that we had the whole set covered with
rain machines but we knew that the rain
was only just reading on camera and so
we diminished the sound of the droplets
hitting the microphone and all of the
hard surfaces as much as we possibly
could the next thing we did was we spoke
to Samantha and we told Samantha that we
wanted to use two radio mics at all
times so that we knew that if a droplet
of rain unluckily got straight into the
radio mic because you
you can see here here's my radio mic I'm
not going to touch it because it will
sound horrible
but if a droplet of rain suddenly lands
in that radio mic we wanted to have
another one to make sure that we could
protect that performance and not have to
cut the camera because of course it
wouldn't be fair on the actress not to
be able to give her a full take and to
keep cutting because of technical
difficulties so we rigged her with two
radio mics the next thing we did was we
spoke about my sound trainee his job on
that was we had a tent just out the back
of the set and he had a hairdryer in
that tent and what his job was to do was
every time Samantha finish to take he
would take those two radio mics off he'd
rerigged with another two radio mics
okay and while we were shooting the next
take he'd be drying the previous two
that he took off for the hairdryer okay
so that we knew that we had basically
dry new radio mics on every single take
that only tells part of the story we
then started talking about the boom we
obviously we like to give the sound
design team a choice afterwards on the
whole of lamia's and that choice was do
you want to use the LaValley a which is
the radio mic or do you want to use a
boom that choice is a choice that's best
made in the dub when the film has been
cut when we could understand the
orchestration and how loud it needed to
go it's a it's certainly a choice that's
best made afterwards rather than on the
set what a good production sound mixer
does is he gives a great radio might
track in a great boom track so that
choice can be made so the boom we found
was over Sam's head and it's running
around about it's running there just on
top of her forehead just out of frame
and what the boom operator did was we
had the second boom operator and in he
was booming over the top of the first
boom operator but he didn't have a
microphone on the end of his pole what
he actually had was a roof okay
he had a 1 foot square okay rooftop
which he hovered via his boom over the
top of the main boom and so you've got
the microphone and then you've got the
second boom shielding that microphone
from the droplets of rain so that the
rains landing on the top of the roof so
it's not landing on the microphone
so what we got out of that scene was
just like the rest of lame is we got
hugely emotive performance that Samantha
didn't have to re-record
that scene the way that you hear it in
the movie was the scene that Samantha
sang on the movie set
and it was hugely inspiring to be able
to capture that under those
circumstances